the royal family has survived multiple
scandals but this time the queen's own
son is accused of sexually abusing a 17
year old and while the case has been
settled for an undisclosed sum with no
admission of liability the story is far
from over maintaining the monarchy
that that can only really happen if it's
what the public want and while perhaps
it seems the queen will ride it out as
the royal family looks to protect their
reputation attention will undoubtedly
turn to the man next in line to the
throne so how damaging will this
continue to be for the royals and prince
charles as a future king
it's a picture that haunts the entire
royal family in it prince andrew has his
arm around virginia roberts dufrey who
was suing him for sexually abusing her
in 2001 on three separate occasions
i was recruited at a very young age from
mar-a-lago
and entrapped in a world that i didn't
understand and i've been fighting that
very world to this day but now a
settlement for an undisclosed sum and a
substantial donation to mr frey's
charity supporting victims of abuse
means the prince will avoid the intense
pressure of a high-profile trial he has
always vimitly denied the allegations
made against him and i've just wished to
reiterate
and to reaffirm the statements which
have already been made on my behalf
by [ __ ] palace i don't think anyone
could have quite predicted then just how
much things would escalate
if it was 20 years ago um they would
have another 20 years of the queen's
reign in which to you know sort of try
and move on and rush things over but um
they don't have that so it's uh you know
it's a kind of a perfect storm of
uh really difficult times ahead i think
he's uh disgraced the royal family
and he should pay the price for that do
you think you should step back from sort
of public duties and from from
everything now yeah yeah i do
prince andrew was stripped of all his
military roles and told that he can no
longer officially and publicly use his
hrh title but what we're waiting to find
out is whether that is enough to sway
public opinion in the family's favor
this is not like the other scandals the
allegations made against him are far
worse than anything that's embroiled the
family before but the family's past
approach to negative press may well give
some insight into how things will play
out
millions watched as diana poured her
heart out on the bbc's panorama program
in 1995.
in it she said she'd become a problem
for the royal family since her split
from prince charles
they are telling me that diana princess
of wales has died this is according to
british sources waking up on the 31st of
august 1997 to the shocking news that
diana had died the public waited for the
palace to respond it took two hours to
cut diana from the wreckage of the
vehicle the queen prince of wales and
the princess's two sons have been told
instead the tabloids filled the void
i think diana's life and death was
instructive for the queen and the royal
family and in fact the queen in the
broadcast that she made finally in the
days that followed diana's death
actually acknowledged that that there
were lessons to be learned we've all
been trying in our different ways to
cope while on the face of it the royal
family managed to weather this difficult
period diana's legacy still looms large
over the palace particularly over prince
charles her criticism of the royal
family and how they treated her came
back into the spotlight thanks to her
son prince harry
when they opened up to oprah harry and
megan again hit the reputation of the
monarchy hard especially in the eyes of
younger people polling last year
revealed that just 31 of 18 to 24 year
olds said they wanted the monarchy to
continue
you know the monarchy is on borrowed
time i think that the prospect of george
sending to the phone
is shrinking i don't think i don't think
he's a definite
uh
no but i mean i think that is shrinking
public opinion over the years has been
divided about how the royal family have
dealt with the likes of diana harry and
megan and probably less so prince andrew
but what has been clear with all of
those examples is that no family member
has ever been more important than
defending the reputation of the
institution and there is one
lesser-known story about how far the
queen will go to protect it
in 1953 peter townsend asked the queen's
sister princess margaret to marry him he
was 16 years older than her and already
divorced with two children from his
previous marriage
margaret was 22 at the time and under
the royal marriages act of 1772 had to
ask the queen's consent to get married
according to documents in the national
archive the queen told her sister if she
did marry mr townsend she'd have to
renounce her rights of succession and
those of her children
it was about the personal and the
professional the family and the firm and
you know the lesson that really i think
runs through the queen's reign is that
when it comes down to it it's the firm
over family princess margaret released a
statement saying she was putting her
duty to the commonwealth above all else
and would therefore not be marrying him
and it's that word duty that's remained
at the heart of elizabeth's reign above
all else i think that's
really um dates back in a sense from
the seminal moment which was the
abdication of edward viii the queen's
uncle
and
essentially
it wasn't even the scandal of an
american divorcee and all of that it was
about
putting family and personal preference
over
the firm the institution the role and
the responsibility that comes with that
and
the queen's father had to step up um
against his kind of preference and
against really his character of being
somebody who was quite shy and retiring
to be king
there is no getting away from it the
royal family can appear ruthless when
their reputation
is at stake but the queen is no longer
the only senior royal who wants to
protect it with the biggest vested
interest coming from her son and our
future king prince charles so can he
survive this latest scandal
set against the rest of the royals
prince charles ranks seventh in
popularity with the public
but the picture gets worse when it's
just millennials voting he drops to 11th
can i ask you a view on your
brother's position
how do you feel
talking about abolishing the monarchy
that is a very big step to take and it's
something that actually
has to happen because of a huge strength
of feeling and
because parliament will then change the
system of how our country is structured
very clearly charles and william are
working um
hard to promote themselves in a
particular way to try and circumvent all
of these scandals to also get themselves
ready for when they aren't supported by
the queen's presence um you know charles
is going to inherit the throne he's not
going to inherit that respect and
deference that the queen has he's not
going to inherit that
lack of willingness on the part of
everybody else to criticize him and to
challenge him you have defended our laws
and certainly given us cause
to shout with heart and voice
god save the queen
as the palace prepare for the platinum
jubilee they're going to try and do as
much they can to distance themselves
from that media storm around prince
andrew but inevitably a story of this
magnitude will continue to be a
distraction and while for the queen this
is an enormous milestone it is also a
reminder that we do have an ageing
monarch
the royal family know that prince
charles is a figure who continues to
divide public opinion and his popularity
as a future monarch is not guaranteed
there will be sighs of relief within the
palace that an explosive trial involving
his brother seems to have been avoided
within the palace they hope this will be
enough to bury the scandal and secure
the future of an institution his mother
has worked so hard to uphold and protect
[Music]
you